bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 28 avril
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal votre
actualité locale sur saint quentin en
yvelines et pour ouvrir cette édition
une information politique hier soir à
roanne le gall adjoint au maire de meaux
repas organisé dans sa ville
un débat public sur la croissance de
demain trois heures pour débattre autour
de trois grandes thématiques le revenu
universel la formation professionnelle
et les nouvelles croissances trois
personnalités ont animé ce débat jean
michel fourgous le maire d'elancourt
frédéric lefebvre candidat à la primaire
de droite et aurélien véron président du
pld le parti libéral démocrate
les détails avec fanny bourdillon
débattre autour des grands enjeux
économiques de demain
c'était l'objectif de cette réunion
publique organisée à l'hôtel de ville de
mort pas parmi les thématiques abordées
la formation professionnelle les
nouvelles croissances et le revenu
universel un engagement au programme de
frédéric lefebvre candidat à la primaire
de droite
d'abord parce que je défends le revenu
universel et qu'on m'a invité pour en
parler parce que je pense que le vieux
modèle social français est usée jusqu'à
la corde dans moins de dix ans pourra
plus payer les retraites il donc il faut
faire quelque chose il faut éradiquer la
pauvreté
il faut lutter contre le chômage le
parti libéral démocrate est à
l'initiative de ce débat public
jean michel fourgous maire d'elancourt
sous l'étiquette des républicains est
venu défendre sa vision libérale de
l'économie
on se bat beaucoup sur
notamment l'impôt sur la plus value il
faut il faut se mettre au niveau
européen il faut une convergence fiscale
de beaucoup d'impôts il faut qu'on soit
là même compétitivité que nos amis
européens sinon voila sinon on va
revivre des moments très difficiles dans
qu' il s'agit de simplifier la vie des
entreprises
hmm hmm également la ville d'entreprise
l'organisation le code du travail tout
comme le républicain frédéric lefebvre
le parti libéral-démocrate et depuis peu
engagés dans la course présidentielle
avec la candidature de rama yade
le parti libéral démocrate défend une
candidature qui était annoncé le jeudi
dernier celle de rama yade et donc on
est derrière rama yade qui est en train
de 2,2 d'avoir une vision très
rénovatrice et de la politique pour
déverrouiller cette démocratie que
beaucoup de français aujourd'hui
contestée est critique
et puis déverrouiller aussi tous les
monopoles les réglementations les
bureaucraties qui noir c'est le
quotidien
la prochaine réunion organisée par le
pld tournera autour du régime des
indépendants le rsi elle aura lieu le
lundi 9 mai à paris et prenons à présent
la direction de trappes le mois dernier
ils étaient douze à se rendre à
co-prévenus tx en république tchèque
douze membres du conseil des jeunes de
la ville de trappes team ont rendu
visite à leurs homologues de la ville
jumelle cette semaine ce sont les jeunes
tchèques qui sont venus en france ils
sont venus passer une semaine pour
découvrir les traditions et les valeurs
françaises avec l'aide des jeunes
trappistes il était mercredi dernier en
mairie de trappes pour une visite des
services municipaux williams elle les a
rencontrés les temps du second dont la
plupart c'est un rêve qui devient
réalité
vingt membres du conseil des jeunes de
la ville de coprim nietzsche et en
république tchèque ont été accueillis
par leurs homologues trappistes de ville
jumelle rassembler autour du programme
erasmus plus c'est un programme
d'échangé européen erasmus plus le
premier temps
nos jeunes à nos jeunes de trappes sont
partis en république tchèque à coprim
initiée pendant une semaine
le deuxième temps pour le coup là c'est
nous qui recevront directement les
chèques chez nous attrape et le
troisième temps là c'est un peu
particulier donc nos jeunes trappistes
repartiront directement à co-prévenus
che en présence également de polonais
voilà pour impulser la création d'un
nouveau conseil des jeunes
une semaine chargée pour les adolescents
visite du château de versailles ou
encore du sénat
mais aujourd'hui c'est la mairie de
trappes qu'il découvre l'engagement dans
un conseil de jeunes c'est une démarche
humaine s'est pas seulement une démarche
technique philosophie culturel c'est
avoir envie de ne pas s'occuper que de
soi et de s'occuper aussi des autres de
sa ville mais aussi de deux de ses
camarades de lycée et notre live un
échange de valeur mais aussi l' envie de
partager sa culture même si ici
communication rime avec traduction ya
leur traductrice qui est là pour nous
aider
c'est juste que c'était tchèque et nous
on est français mais on on échange nos
projets tels que je dise kosice scène
j'ai toujours voulu venir en france et
voir paris alors c'est une très bonne
occasion d'être là et de se faire des
amis en plus il y en a qui parlent
anglais mais la plupart du temps des
échanges avec la ville de coprim
nietzsche et existe depuis les années 70
mais c'est une première pour le conseil
des jeunes qui préparent déjà leur
deuxième voyage
et nous recevons ce soir mon plateau
xavier bonvarlet vice-président de
balises qui la banque alimentaire sur 50
ans une usine bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors vous
organiser un concert mardi 3 mai à la
salle jacques-brel de montigny le
bretonneux pour pour la cession d'une
balise qui ce que vous pouvez nous
parler un peu plus nous dire comment va
se dérouler l'événement
alors c'est un événement qui se produit
pour la troisième fois dans la salle
jacques brel à montigny c'est un concert
qui est un petit peu victime de son
succès puisque avant ça se passait à
voisins le bretonneux dans la salle de
la tour qui est un peu plus petit et
c'est vrai que l'ensemble concertiste et
de qualité et la salle jacques brel qui
permet d'accueillir plus de 300
personnes nous permettra également de
recevoir davantage de fonds parce que
c'est ça aussi l'objectif balises qui a
besoin de compléter ses ressources
outre les subventions outre
éventuellement des partenariats avec des
entreprises d'organiser des événements
culturels
alors les fonds vont être reversés à
l'association est pourquoi nous rappeler
rapidement pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas avalé ski
comment elle fonctionne et son rôle très
bien alors ben ali ce qui existe depuis
20 ans à l'origine un partenariat entre
le département la communauté
d'agglomération le secours catholique
et puis quatre villes guyancourt montini
voisins et manie le coeur le coeur de
vie de l'association
c'est l'accompagnement de familles qui
ont un projet qui a été validé par les
travailleurs sociaux du département et
balises qui travaille en étroite
collaboration avec les travailleurs
sociaux pour permettre à ces familles de
sortir en quelque sorte et des
difficultés auxquelles elles sont
confrontées et tous les mois il ya une
commission qui se réunit qui regroupe
des bénévoles de ben ali ce qui des
représentants des ccas des villes
concernées des travailleurs sociaux pour
voir quelles sont les familles
susceptibles d'intégrer la démarche
d'accompagnement ben ali ce qui alors ce
concert que vous organisez donc le 3 mai
c'est voilà c'est un événement assez
festif
justement pour récolter des fonds et la
sq avec la baisse des dotations de
l'état ou du département vous craignez
pour votre trésorerie sur les raisons
pour qu'elle vous avez organisé cet
événement c'est vrai qu'on aime un peu
quelques inquiétudes
alors le financement de balises qui
dépend de trois sources
il ya d'une part les marchandises qui
sont achetés 40% moins chers que les
prix hypermarchés par les filles par les
familles pardon qui fréquentent balises
qui deuxième source de financement des
subventions le département la communauté
d'agglomération et puis quatre villes ça
ne suffit pas donc il faut chercher les
financements par ailleurs des
entreprises et des manifestations
culturelles
c'est vrai qu'à ce jour on ne connaît
pas encore ce que seront les subventions
du département et de saint quentin en
yvelines
les autres villes montini voisin lui en
cours nous ont fait savoir qu'elle
maintenait le montant de la subvention
la situation devient de plus en plus
compliqué pour les associations
aujourd'hui à pour les associations
général louis c'est vrai bon pour ben
ali ce qui on a la grosse satisfaction
d'avoir l'approbation de tous nos
politiques que ce soit le département
que ce soit le président de la
communauté d'agglomération que ce soit
aussi les maires des quatre villes et
même des deux députés françois de
mazières pour montigné guyancourt
et puis l'année dernière valérie
pécresse pour magny les hameaux et
voisins qui nous ont aidés en prélève en
s'en prenant vente mais nous sommes sur
leur réserve parlementaire
nous sommes très bien considéré par le
département on a encore une réunion la
semaine dernière on dit ben ali ce qui
c'est indispensable
maintenant je peux pas juger de ce que
ce projet financement
merci et xavier bon parler lors je le
rappelle le conservera lieu donc le 3
mai la saq et à sale pardon jacques brel
à montigny le bretonneux
si vous souhaitez plus d'informations
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le site
internet de balistique qui s'affiche en
bas de votre écran et son mot de
bienvenue tout le monde est bienvenu
exactement économie à présent
actuellement en phase de travaux sky
cube le futur incubateur de saint
quentin en yvelines devrait ouvrir ses
portes en novembre prochain
son rôle sera d'accompagner pendant une
période allant de 12 à 24 mois
start up du territoire à faner
bourdillon nous en dit plus d'ici fin
novembre 2016 sont quentin en yvelines
aura son incubateur appelé sky cube ce
futur pôle de l'entrepreneuriat réunira
différents services pour aider les
startups de demain si on veut que nos
entrepreneurs ils réussissent
durablement
est-ce qu'il ya souvent une entreprise
sur deux qui tombe quasiment dans les
cinq premières années
il faut plus bétonné ses différentes
phases de croissance d'une entreprise
pas nous leur apprendrons leur apprend à
comment bénéficier d'un crédit impôt
recherche comment déposer un brevet
comment trouver un partenaire financier
durable
situé à 200 mètres de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines l'incubateur
accueillera une vingtaine de start up
sur une surface de 1000 m² et trois
niveaux
dès qu'il y en a une qui est en en
gommant ça grossier papon la passe au
deuxième étage donc à promo paul oui à
la pépinière où là il ya d'autres
services plus adaptés à un niveau de
maturité
oui c'est quand même une étape web
d'accélération pour pour les plus jeunes
pour les jeunes en taule
d'expérimentation sky cube c'est aussi
des espaces de travail des salles de
visioconférence et des bases
documentaires une structure nécessaire
pour les jeunes pousses du territoire
le tout pour un budget de 3 millions
d'euros
les élèves vont bientôt reprendre la
route de l'école et pendant les vacances
de printemps les jeunes des longs cours
eux ont décidé de se mettre à la radio
un atelier pour les sensibiliser aux
médias et leur apprendre leur apprendre
l'expression orale nous sommes allés à
la rencontre de ces apprentis
journalistes et animateurs pendant
l'enregistrement de leurs émissions dans
un studio camille lambert et fanny
bourdillon pour ce reportage micro
casque et papier ces jeunes d'elancourt
sont prêts pour leurs premiers
enregistrements radio il travaille
pendant les vacances de printemps pour
créer leurs émissions ils ont réalisé
eux mêmes les reportages voulez parler
du championnat d'europe presque passé le
10 juin 21h de mars avaient choisi de
parler de notre message j'ai choisi de
parler de la vision des saignements bas
puisque c'est ce qui m'est venue l'idée
c'est surtout bas j'aime bien les
animaux c'est passionnant
comment récolter des informations
l'étrier écrire un sujet autant
d'exercices abordé avec l'aide
d'animateurs un atelier proposé au
centre de loi
dire pour faire découvrir les médias une
première pour la ville donc vous avez
fait un reportage sur les bouchons
d'espoir pour vous nous en parler
exact on a passé on a posé des questions
à claude apprendre à s'exprimer en
public
l'aisance de la parole je pense que
c'est aussi un des objectifs de l'école
ça peut être aussi un objectif des
centres de loisirs
ça leur donne aussi un pouvoir
d'expression quelque part voilà donc ils
sont enchantés face à la motivation des
enfants la mairie prévoit déjà d'
organiser d'autres ateliers du même
genre
l'émission sera disponible en streaming
sur le réseau de la ville
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis et à demain vous
retrouvez à wilfrid errishi pour
l'essentiel de l'actu et sephora namani
pour le circuito week-end quant à moi je
vous retrouve l lundi pour une nouvelle
édition du journal
je vous souhaite donc à une bonne soirée
et un excellent week-end